counting this is work that's done
jointly with Mickey I tie it is a kind
of funny history which I will explain so
but before I start my talk I I want to
start by you know paying tribute to
Mickey I tie who recently retired from
from IBM Alvin and so I think of the
stock more as a tribute to him he's
enjoying his retirement and we know that
you know Mickey has done some
fundamental part breaking work in many
different areas including you know
circuit complexity times the stray dogs
branching programs lattices data
structures in some sense every topic
that either in this workshop or even in
the workshop in the parallel program you
know Mickey has had it that's a huge you
know imprint there but actually he was
also interested in very practical
questions so that one of the most
successful patterns in IBM was something
that had to do with differential backup
which is this was before the days of all
this time machine and things like that
that people use on their Macs for
example for backup so he had a very
successful patent in that and I actually
happened to look up this you know patent
portfolio and it turns out that he also
has a patent on mechanical towers of
Hanoi puzzle so so yeah so and in some
sense the streaming thing that led to
this particular question so he was
actually interested in streaming
questions as well and in fact it was in
the context of working with him along
with Ravi and and ravi kumar and shiva
kumar that sort of this question arose
and that particular streaming work had
to do with you know arguably the first
streaming problem where the order of
elements matter so it's some measure of
sort redness so so one thing that always
stuck with me
is back you know I will talk to Ravi
about and Shiva but you know
houses that he actually comes up with
these you know statements in his papers
that you know seems so hard to parse
even the statement of the lemma and and
well I'm the statement that Robbie said
was you know most of us tend to think in
Sigma to mickey starts with Sigma for so
I think that's the most happy thing to
say about him so okay so so the work I'm
presenting in some sense is
anachronistic because this thing was
done almost ten years ago or more than
ten years ago
and primarily by by Mickey and sort of
we have some further you know
improvements but we have actually not
none of this had actually been written
up and in some sense maybe I should have
waited before all this is done but then
I thought you know this workshop is
properly you know the most you know
appropriate to actually present this
thing so disclaimer is that the problem
is since it's so old it's possible that
what I'm claiming today may actually
already be known through a combination
of you know some previous work so so if
that's the case you know please come and
you know talk to me and at the end of my
talk I think I tried to do a fair
assessment myself of whether the problem
is still in a open end so at the very
least anyway the proof I hope is at
least interesting even if the result you
feel is not new okay so let me start so
okay so comping in a stream so this is
arguably the sort of the oldest problem
in streaming I mean going back to 78
paper of Robert Morris for approximate
counting and the interesting thing is
that it's a problem this is a randomized
or problems tic algorithm that uses
space log log n and all you need to ID
to tell you about that algorithm is you
know come up with a random variable such
that the expected value of 2 to the X or
X is a random variable the Z plus 1
where C is the number of ones in a
stream of length and this problem
continues will you know have interest
for various reasons so there is a
recent papers include a floating-point
version of this particular algorithm and
also surprisingly applications to flash
memory where the important thing about
this algorithm is not as much does not
as much the fact that it actually
approximates decent claim and that's
good but more importantly that you make
very few updates to the probabilistic
counter itself so and in flash memory
you care about how many rights you make
because each time you write it D creates
the performance of of the memory so any
way it needs to generate interest and
also you know it has led to this
beautiful work in in analytic
combinatorics starting with the work of
you know Phillips la Jolie and various
others are not least all the people here
and interestingly flagella sort of got
interested in this problem because
somebody from IBM San Jose at that time
this is one before which became IBM
Almaden later contacted him and told him
they want to implement this but there's
no proper analysis so so he started with
that they're trying to analyze this and
that's what led to his own beautiful
work on you know distinct elements and
you know hyper log-log and goes that
line of work so ok so having said
everything about the the sort of
probabilistic case so what about
deterministic algorithms
ok so we know that you know I mean this
is the way people usually motivate this
thing is that ok I I can if I want to
count it exactly I need you know login
space because there are n plus 1 values
to output so let's do probabilistic
right introduced but you can ask you
know what happened if if I actually oh I
want to still use only deterministic
algorithms and I want to get some
multiplicative approximation so this
this information theoretic bound is not
enough because they're only login values
to output so it seems like that will
give you only log log in so yeah so so
that's going to be the subject of this
talk
now if you say okay I only care about
uniform algorithms so just think of it
as you know uniform not in the
traditional sense but more in the sense
that you have an automata but you're not
counting time explicitly then this
question apparently was not solved until
somebody recently observed that actually
there is a simple argument that gives an
Omega N lower bound for or this case so
it's so uniform is basically finite
automaton and I'll describe this
argument adapted to our settings so so
what do I mean by these things that
suppose I give you an automata and I'm
supposed to count the number of ones in
the stream or approximately count the
number of ones in the stream so so
suppose the number of states say only at
most n to be 1 over 16 so you're trying
to prove a log n lower bound on space so
suppose the strange says number of
states is already small then sort of you
know it's a very simple thing so you
start by you know feeding this automaton
a lot of zeroes until it starts to cycle
right so right so you feed it zeros
until it starts to cycle and then you
feed it a bunch of ones and then again
starts to cycle I mean I haven't drawn
it in a manner that these states are
distinct from these states but they need
not be it's just convenient to view this
picture this way and then what you do is
you try to find sequences so that the
amount of time spent in this cycle is
equal to the amount of time spent in
this cycle and you just maximize this
thing so on the floor on the one hand by
spending a lot of time on this cycle you
have too many zeros and spending a lot
of time on this cycle have too many ones
so you can basically produce these two
states where you know on the one hand
the count I is at most n over 8
177 and over 8 so you actually get the
world one that you mean so now the
question is sort of what happens with
with non-uniform algorithms and that's
what I'm going to be talking about so so
what do I mean by non-uniform is
basically branching programs
okay so we've all seen branching
programs in several talks but in this
case it's actually a very restricted
type of branching program referred to as
obdd so it's basically you know a
leveled branching program and it's
oblivious because you read the same
variable in each time step and and it's
read once so right so in fact
interestingly when I was initially
working on on streaming I I think
streaming earthing it wasn't then very
fancy or popular then then people would
ask me isn't hey this is just obdd why
are you doing streaming okay
what's so cool about it so anyway so so
yeah but in terms of actually proving
lower bounds yeah we are in some sense
thinking about obdds so okay right so
that's the sense in which I'm saying
it's non-uniform now not thus
non-uniformity actually help well at
least for the instances that I gave
earlier non-uniformity will it can
actually help distinguish these two sets
of inputs you know remember I said there
are zeros followed by one in both cases
but it's just that the number of zeros
is huge here and number of one's is huge
here so certainly you can distinguish
these two classes of inputs by a very
simple obdd you know just check the
value at the middle right so so in some
sense yeah so the value of the middle
will be that in this case it will be 0
and in this case it will be 1 just by
the nature of
the imports that are constructed here
and basically this is saying that you
can actually use another way to state
this is that you can actually use the
clock to your advantage so basically by
saying that I'm checking the value at n
over 2 and basically saying okay look at
the clock as a counter and and wait
until the most significant bit becomes 1
and at that point check the input that
you're really ok so it's a very simple
use of the clock and I couldn't sort of
resist the temptation to sort of you
know present this other cute algorithm
due to Parekh shift and NJ kumar that
actually uses the clock in a in a more
sophisticated way so let me just present
this thing enough that I'll talk about
it so so yeah you're interested in
finding duplicates and your domain is of
size M but the stream length is really
huge it suffice to to the m and the way
the algorithm works is that you
basically use the clock itself sort of
to remember the elements that you've
seen in the stream so far so one at a
particular position indicates that you
have seen this element sometime in the
past okay but it's not an if and only if
things like you know there are no false
positives if you see a one then suddenly
there's a if a better set to one in the
clock you have certainly seen it before
but you're not remembering all the
elements that you have seen before so
but certain that invariant is going to
be maintained and you can see what
happens is that ok when you read the
current symbol because the invariant if
it is if the clock at that particular J
is equal to one then because of the
invariant you have seen it before and
therefore you have found the duplicate
right so otherwise it's zero ok what
you're going to do is you are going to
advance the clock until that particular
position becomes 1 now this is always
guaranteed to work because of the stream
length being huge and is at least 2 to
the M so the clock will at some point
get to the point where clock of another
J position is
equal to one now during this process
okay what happens is that okay you have
a zero here and to the right of it you
know it's a bunch of ones and as you're
waiting for this zero to turn into one
all these ones become zeros so it's a
about forgetting things that you have
seen before but you're never introducing
a false positive so when it actually at
the end ends up becoming one you are in
fact you know maintaining that invariant
because in fact before this when the
loop started you had actually seen just
before so and this is since this is the
only place where the program can
actually terminate this actually
produces the correct answer so non
uniformity in this case actually helps
in a very big way basically okay maybe
in this example you can see the clock
when I said it looked for the most
significant bit to be one that's like
saying look at the wait until you are
looking at xn over 2 so the clock when
you're doing tests on clocks you're
basically saying in these but these
layers are special yes because only
place that this algorithm can terminate
is here because of the stream length is
the stream length is large that's
crucial so it cannot terminate this will
not abort because you know that it is
not like a bad statement here this will
certainly succeed so only player because
of the loop here the only place that you
can terminate is here just guarantee to
donate because the stream length is is
only is finite so it also terminates out
there because where can it run out right
the only place it can run out is here
where it says hey I don't have any more
elements to check but this is always
guaranteed to work because if the clock
at that particular bit is zero at some
point it will become one because the
stream length is at least 2 to the N
it's a quite a simple but clever use of
the clock this is not another thing to
watch him talking about but I thought
you know to just tell you that clocks
can be used cleverly although I don't
know if there are any practical uses of
such things okay famous last words
[Music]
no it probably with a law a log M
because you have to remember the current
symbol but I think the the thing that
the point is that I think if for general
duplicate finding you know when you
don't have you know can't play such
tricks you will need linear in ml or
something like that log n which is like
you know or something like that in this
case you can actually get longer
okay so so anyway so with that you know
being mentioned so let me then describe
the main result of this particular talk
is that any would be really that
actually two approximates the count need
space
you know how may God login so that's the
desert I want to present and I hope to
present the proof in its entirety
because it's with Pauline Pauline we
sail off to the one-third M or something
I'm sorry no it's weight n to the one
third so like yeah okay so so even
though I'm talking about to
approximation the result actually I mean
just works even for multiplicative and
to the data approximation and I won't
mention this thing but it is the lower
bound technique works or something more
general called monotonic counters but I
won't I want to find what that is right
so the result is clear now
all right so what I want to do now is I
want to you know give some some notation
and and then then then dive into the
proof so okay so so I'll start with you
know this notation of okay so an
interval basically I look at every node
and look at all the possible counts that
reach that particular node
okay now in general this need not be an
interval right that it can miss some of
the elements in the middle but all I
care about is the minimum and the
maximum of the counts that are reached
there I'm saying that it's an interval
it's just a convenient way to talk about
properties of that rather than having to
say for the minimum this holds or the
maximum of the Scorch is just too
convenient way to state things so for
example at the root it's going to be 0 0
and look at this particular node so this
branching program I didn't mention
earlier computes parity so at this
particular node you should get all the
inputs that I have parity 0 all and this
column it's all about inputs that get
parity one
so here the valid input should be only 0
and and 2 but since I'm throwing away
information about you know things in
between so I'm just saying it's an
interval from 0 to 2 right ok and so
that's a note that's an interval
reaching a node and at each level or
each time T I only care about the
maximal intervals at that particular
level so in this example of again at
this particular level so so the ones
that are in red are the ones that are
not maximal because in this particular
layer you see that you know 0 to
subsumes this one 1 so I don't care
about these intervals I only care about
the maximal intervals and of course the
number of intervals at any particular
level or number of maximal in intervals
at any particular level is sort of a
simple you know gives you a way to bound
the space so lower bound this way so
anyway so I'm interested in counting how
many maximal into
they are there in each level and in
particular show that there must be some
level where there's a lot of maximum
intervals so what are some simple
properties of this is that you know if
you know that there is an interval KL at
some node if it's an interval at time T
meaning that you know it's some node is
labeled by that particular interval then
then at time T plus 1
there must be an interval containing KL
and there must be an interval containing
K plus 1 l plus 1 this is simply due to
the fact that you know if I might just
say this node out here right and I read
a 0 right then this node here will
suddenly get the smallest and the
largest it may get more than then what's
there then just the minimum and the
maximum but but but the statement is
that it contains KL and that's certainly
true and the same thing holds because
when you read a 1 the same thing happens
is that you know since K and L of the
minimum L are the minimum and the
maximum when you read a 1 you will be
getting k plus 1 and L plus 1 but there
may be other stuff that reaches there so
that for the rest of the proof I could
have just done this thing once I have
done this thing with stating family of
intervals 1 4 where in each level or
rather a family of sets of intervals
right right each level has a little
collection of maximal intervals and I
have one per time or one third level and
I could have just proceeded with the
rest of the proof just purely as a
combinatorial exercise looking at this
particular family but I will still stick
with the branching program sort of you
know intuition because it's easier to
reason in what I'm presenting
so right so okay so so this is I perhaps
the most important notion here so it's
the notion of disappearing counts so we
say a particular count K is present at
time T right the if it turns out to be
the left endpoint of one of the maximal
intervals at time T so so there is some
interval K comma L which is maximal for
some L and K is sort of the left
endpoint so when I say it's a case
present I mean K is the left endpoint so
when I say present think left endpoint
so one comment is that zero is going to
be present at all times because it is
sort of the boundary right you cannot go
smaller than it so there must be always
something that has zero as a left
endpoint at all time now count K
disappears during time T if it is
present at time T but it's actually
absent at time T plus one it's not
present there okay so this is sort of a
natural notion that says that hey this
is going to be bad for me in terms of
approximation because it was present at
time T but I have seemed to have lost
the information that I read at one
because there was no interval in level T
plus one or time T plus 1 that has K
plus 1 as a as a left endpoint so these
are times in which something bad has
happened right so I was trying to think
of a nice picture to draw here and and
the closest I could think of was to draw
a picture of Dracula so literally is a
count and he keeps appearing and
disappearing in the movies but it was
too cute to put it there so anyway so
but the important thing to remember is
it's present at time T but absent at
time T plus also the main lemma is that
suppose that these counts cannot
actually disappear too many times okay
so if a count K disappears the times
these positive then act termination
there is an interval containing K need
not be the left endpoint which is an
interval containing K whose right right
endpoint is at least K plus B okay so of
course if you're interested in good
approximations then you cannot allow D
to be too large because given an
interval at the end it's a large
interval so the minimum is this maximum
this is what are you going to output
right because output or something the
middle or something the left or on the
right doesn't matter it's like going to
kill your approximation loss of
generality let's assume there's only we
hold or put the value in which is the
minimum of the accounts that means so so
this is trying to say that you know if
you had a good approximation then you
cannot have it disappear too many times
so let me talk about that the proof of
this thing okay so I'm just going to
illustrate this proof for the case that
D equals two so this is probably the
most you know technical of all the
slides so but it's quite simple so
suppose so this node in purple is one of
those places where K disappears and it's
then it's present in this time step but
it's actually absolutely
Dada okay so KL is an interval at this
particular time step at time that's at
time T at T plus one I claim that there
is an interval I 1 that contains K comma
L plus 1 so let me run through this
argument so by the property I mentioned
here earlier that if I be a 1 there
should be certainly an interval at level
T plus 1 that contains K plus 1 and L
plus 1 but you read a 1 so k plus 1 and
plus 1 so some something out here
contains K plus 1 l plus 1 and I'm
cheating slightly by saying that it's
the node exactly where I've read the 1
nevermind so so I one suddenly contains
K plus 1 l plus 1 but because it
disappears during time T plus 1 it
cannot be the case that k plus 1 is the
left endpoint so it must be that it
actually also contains K and L plus 1
right
so so here's an interval that contains
now K and L plus 1 and then what we do
is we run this branching program by
feeding it a bunch of zeros until we hit
the next time where K does again it's
disappearing act
ok it's present here but absent here so
in that case what happens is that ok so
you're reading a bunch of zeros you have
an interval that contains K and L plus 1
but because you are feeding it only
zeros there must be some interval J one
that contains K and L plus 1 if you are
not done any changes but it was add more
stuff that's why it's always containment
so what have we done here they have done
here that is at the first time here it
started to ask al now we have a new
interval with K containing K and it's
right endpoint is at least L plus 1 ok
now we have to repeat the same argument
again but to repeat the argument again I
need an interval whose left endpoint is
K but fortunately I'm in a time step
where K is going to do its disappearing
act so it actually appears here right so
there must be some other node here that
K is the left endpoint ok and L prime
says it's its right endpoint now here's
a maximality comes in because because
it's also a maximal interval it cannot
be that L prime is you know smaller than
L plus 1 because then this interval
would be strictly contained in j-1 so
maximality ensures that this interval
also strictly contains K L plus 1 so
what you have achieved is that from KL
we went to K L plus 1 we have sort of
increased the this thing the right
endpoint by at least one and then you
keep repeating this argument
something intervals for all the notes
all these four notes for which the
maximum inside of their specific time
step right so this picture is somewhat
misleading because when I say one
there's an interval that contains K plus
and L plus one it need not be this note
because this may not be the one that's
maximal it's maybe sitting somewhere
else out here so these arrows are just
some sort of misleading in minute sense
but but yeah Mac somatically does play
an important role
all right so so okay so again if so this
was the lemma right that there was if it
appears at least the times then it
appears three times then there's an
interval whose right endpoint is at
least K plus D so all we need to do is
you know put this all together and I'm
the best way to describe what the
strategy is in the header so okay so you
fix a set of counts in this case it's
going to be the zero to n to the one to
it and and the previous lemma said that
because of the multiplicative
approximation K cannot appear too many
times disappear too many times because
if it I disappear too many times then
it's right endpoint will be at least two
K and then we'll be violating the two
approximation so a count K can have
disappear at most k times and then a
Union bound says that the number of
times during which some count in C
disappears is at most n to the 2/3 n to
the 2/3 values each one of them can
disappear at most n to be one third
times so it's n to the 2/3 so therefore
by pigeonhole principle there is a
contiguous block time of length n to the
one third during which no count in C
disappears this is a very standard thing
I went a bit fast over this but to
finish up given that contiguous block of
time there are no count from C
disappears you can basically construct
this branching programs I'm almost done
so let me just finish this and this one
more slide so this is the idea here
would be that you start with you know
that node there there
left endpoint is zero because zero is
present at all times as you feed zeroes
you will always see some interval where
zero is the left endpoint and then you
say that okay because zero did not
disappear there must be an interval
containing 1 as the left endpoint and
similarly here in this time step neither
0 nor 1 disappears so there must be 1
with 1 as the left endpoint and 2 was
the left endpoint and so on and so a
time n to the one third because that's
the length of the block you have lots of
intervals ok so let me finish up by
saying some something else because so
this problem of approximating the count
certainly you know has been considered
in in other contexts as well so for
example if you allow negative counts you
just know that the space required is
actually Omega log n so I mean this is
due to a sequence of two papers with
these authors I think Ely and David are
in both papers and what this show is
that it's a beautiful result that
applies to a very broad class of
problems when they say that linear
sketches of y4 suffice for don't start
straining so so there's no violation of
the two approximation at the moment all
I'm trying to get here is that there are
lots of intervals at a particular level
the violation of the thing has already
been used in in the earlier part
okay so right so so they suffice for
turnstile streaming but this is this
critically depends on negative counts
and it does not hold in our setting
because if you want to check say if the
count is zero what does that mean you
want to check that all the bits in your
stream are zero right that's a very easy
check to do but if you apply linear
sketching linear sketching means you
know computed mod a small number of you
know Prime's or counts okay then what
happens is that if the modulus the LCM
of all your things is not at least n
then there were at least two values
which have the same sketch so therefore
linear sketching doesn't help in this
case so but it turns out that actually
linear sketching could be useful so
there's an earlier branching program
result that tells you how to compute
branching programs for majority and and
I and those branching programs can
actually be used to you poly log in
space but you need poly log and passes
now admittedly this is I think
non-uniform and can be made uniform or
what I think fairly confident but but
it's thank you
[Applause]
the same low bun works into the
approximation approximation right so
that that's one of the things that I
mentioned we are still you know work
like in something like n over 4 - n over
2 or something like in the very high
counts and to approximation yeah that's
still still slope and I think we have
some ideas that can handle that case -
you have to be careful there again
because of this clever use of clocks so
you when you have you here we are mixing
zeros and ones right when you have very
high counts you want to still make sure
that mixing happens so I think that this
argument will not work for sure you have
I think a different argument but I think
the part is probably it is mine because
I have not written it up and so it's not
McKeesport it's mine so anyway I hope to
get this done you know soon so stay
tuned thanks for the question
is it known that there is a trade-off
between number of classes and space I
mean because your result seems it's not
possible to move it further for many
classes right so there's an issue of
randomized versus deterministic adding
most people care about randomized so you
are asking about deterministic so I know
I don't know what the trade of this and
I'm just saying that probably people
haven't studied this question so yeah
there is something some somewhere
there's some transition happening to
poly log and space from from from log
and space but admitted it okay so yeah
so this is all in this non uniform
serving oh I should say poly log log n
yeah sorry my bad I should say log log
in space so everything this is okay this
is a bad statement so right it is it all
poly log log I think everything is order
log log I think they both should be log
loss yeah it's a question of translating
the bounds from here to the setting so I
made I might have messed up
it's been Jeremy
[Applause]